all right here's a story from Bloomberg
Sandy Hook families seek
2.75 trillion dollars from Alex Jones
jury already awarded families 965
million in Damages judge to decide
damages under State deceptive trade law
oh this is fascinating so basically
they're seeking what just just about 3
000 times what they were awarded from
the jury
2.75 trillion let's put that into
context here is a list of countries by
GDP you can see here U.S dollars in the
trillions France 2.77 Canada 2.2 so Alex
Jones's lawsuit Falls somewhere in
between Canada and France in terms of
gross domestic product that's how stupid
we have become as a people I'm ashamed
because look I'm worried the aliens are
watching us and boy is this embarrassing
if they are you know there's there was a
story we talked about the other day that
claimed Putin had already tried to file
fire a nuke but that sabotage or
technical issues cause it not to Fire
and I'm like well the only the only uh
you know the only solution to that or
the only the only answer as to why
that's happening is aliens you know as
soon as you press the button the aliens
deactivate it well that's the conspiracy
theory right that aliens stopped us from
firing nukes I'm just saying the whole
world everything that humanity is we are
becoming a clown show that's how stupid
this is so I think we can take this back
you know we can end this easily going
back to late 1700s Congress shall make
no law abridging freedom of speech now
back in those days that only applied to
Congress right but after the Civil War
we passed this thing called the 14th
Amendment says the states now shall make
no law abridging the freedom of speech
so all of the privileges and immunities
of free speech that were guaranteed in
the Constitution applied to people like
Alex Jones there's modern jurisprudence
as well that backs us up the the Supreme
Court case that you're going to want to
look to to reference this is Brandenburg
versus Ohio this was back in the 1960s
which says that if there's a matter of
public interest or an event of public
interest if you have an opinion about
that event that is free speech so this
Connecticut judge has essentially
invalidated uh you know jurisprudence
which has been you know repeatedly
upheld since the 1960s it's Brandon bird
case has been tried and tested and has
been settled settled case law so Alex
Jones I think goes to the Supreme Court
and wins I don't think it gets tossed
out on appeal I think it goes to the
Supreme Court and I think that they look
at the Brandenburg case and then they
throw this out entirely let me read this
from the story it says the family said
they're entitled to that amount 2.75
trillion because Jones broke a state law
barring the sale of products using false
statements they reached the sum by
multiplying the state laws five thousand
dollar per violation fine by the 550
million social media exposures Jones's
audience received on his Facebook
YouTube and Twitter accounts in the
three years following the San Diego
incident literally makes no sense the
judge made a huge mistake but but in
this in this regard Alex Jones did not
do come maybe I'm wrong okay but I'm
pretty sure he didn't do commercials
where he held up his product and was
like I just want to talk about you know
a tragic event buy my product and also
that event was not real like I'm pretty
sure his commercials were entirely
separate statements it would be like if
you know we we have bio trust sponsors
the show as if they would be liable
because I make a claim about Joe Biden
on the show and that's selling the
product that's nonsense the law is
supposed to be if I said something like
you know this water keeps Tigers away
hundred dollars Ian you want to buy it
well I don't see any tigers do you
that's clearly right that's what they're
trying to go for opinions are always
protected free speech and that's Alex
Jones opinion that that happened and so
as long as it was a clearly stated
opinion about a public event he's
protected so he's never gonna have to
pay this money I mean obviously you know
you guys were talking about it getting
thrown out on appeal but I think that
this goes through the legislative
process goes to the Supreme Court they
say Brandenburg and then it gets tossed
out but you know the left is celebrating
this now as if they're going to go after
all of these other people like you and
me and Kanye and others and stuff I
don't think that happens not with the
Supreme Court the way that it sits right
now when he made a statement and named
one of the parents and said that they
were lying that is across the line is no
longer opinion is that true no no so uh
here's the crazy thing if I said
something like Ian Crossland is a
conservative commentator who actively
assists fascists and I've seen him do it
that's an opinion
if I said I've watched Ian Crossland
walk up to a group of fascists and
provide Aiden support to them that's an
opinion
because what people need to understand
is that
I've talked with lawyers so many times
about defamation stuff like this people
seem to think that claiming someone did
something is a statement of fact when
it's not but what about if I you said
Ian Crossing said he was 43 years old
and he is lying so if you so the
statement of fact is that you said you
were 43 years old did you yes okay
whether you're lying or not is my
opinion whether you said you were 43 is
fact so if I said for instance Ian a
conservative commentator Ian Crossland
said that if Young Folks if we get rid
of no fault divorce Young Folks would be
more careful about who they marry did
you really say that because I made a
statement of fact and a quote like
Jezebel so is it for those that are
familiar this is literally what Jezebel
did to Ian this is a false statement to
fact outright and it is actionable the
next question is Damages were you
damaged by it how much does it cost well
we had one user tell us the other day
they were going to give us a thousand
bucks a month for 84 years but then they
found out Ian was conservative so
they're not gonna so what we'll have to
look into for 2.75 trillion that's right
2.75 marks of people that have watched
the show ever and thought of me in their
head now multiplied by come on so so the
issue with this is that uh Alex Jones
never had a trial that's that's that's
what happened if he did they would have
been like it's a it's a it's an opinion
albeit you might think it's a really
stupid one but it is the judge granted
um discovery which makes no sense I mean
she should have immediately ruled it as
a free speech issue but you know she's
obviously stepped into this on the on a
political side a lot of people think and
I agree Alex should not have said stuff
like this it's it's clearly ridiculous
but he's allowed to you know uh Ethan
Klein got suspended from from YouTube
the other day for the comments he made
about Ben Shapiro getting guessed we
said it on the show that night he should
not get suspended that was before he did
and then I said it again he got banded
he shouldn't be he should be allowed to
say that someone super chatted already
that like I'm criticizing Kanye West for
saying you know I don't know if we're
supposed to say it on the show because
someone's at the R1 yeah but I'm like
you know kind I said Kanye shouldn't I
didn't say he should be banned from
doing it right but what about the
defamation case now in your opinion what
should somebody not be able to say like
when they can prove damages by what
someone said when they're not a public
figure right well so I I I understand
the public figure thing and it's it's
tough right if if we're looking at
someone who is a politician or a
celebrity and they're active in public
life and we have an argument with them I
understand why we have the time see
times V Sullivan precedent that there's
a higher standard for public figures
for people who aren't public figures who
aren't involved in this stuff I
understand why that standard isn't there
so it is difficult my my view of this is
like what really should have happened is
that they sue Alex Jones and said you've
made false statements about this Alex
Jones pays in the thousands and has to
issue an apology out of Attraction I
think one big solution for a lot of
these things is a retraction and apology
but the courts don't ever enforce that
but he's injection right now Alex
already did Issue a lot of apologies no
I know but YouTube deleted all those
videos and there's no record of it right
there's not a lot of records that he
could comply with and this is one of the
reasons why of course they just threw
out the court case and he didn't have
his day in court they just decided he
was guilty said he wasn't complying
maybe he was maybe he wasn't we don't
know the full story of exactly what was
happening behind the scenes here but uh
I don't know maybe these families
confused Alex Jones with the Federal
Reserve and think he could just print
money out of thin air and it's just a
ridiculous notion to ask for trillions
of dollars it shows you how frivolous
this is and how it's politically
motivated rather than motivated on the
actual Marathon of this case yeah I
think I I think the strong possibility
goes to the Supreme Court they might
just say they don't want to hear it but
I think they probably would because this
is kind of ridiculous so here's my
understanding I was uh we went down to
Austin I think it was a year ago
and this was when Jones was right right
on time he was held in default or they
declared a default judgment because he
didn't turn over all the documents
Alex I was talking to him and he said we
have given them every single thing we
have there's nothing else we can give
them and he was like frantically and
adamant being like Tim wasn't like I
gave him literally everything I don't
know what else to do and they just kept
saying he didn't yeah so like what do
you do when they just claim you didn't
give them the documents and you did he's
in chapter 11 which means that in Texas
he's still going to be able to operate
he's got like less than three million
dollars in assets they don't have to
liquidate he can still keep his
employees he can still operationally but
that what they've promised is all the
future profits from and which there
never will be right right let me explain
something to to uh anybody who just
doesn't understand how businesses work
profits are a choice that's it it's a
choice
so they may try and say okay we're gonna
we're gonna find out where you are right
now and we're gonna say here's a cap as
to how much you can use for our
operational costs but that probably
won't fly because it makes no sense
because costs vary so for Alex let's say
he makes three million dollars this year
I I was probably way more a while ago
let's make let's just pick a number
let's say 10 million okay fine
they say okay you made 10 million
dollars
that is revenue not profit Alex can then
take let's say it costs him three
million to run the business he can then
spend seven million dollars on
advertisements all over the country and
that is an operational cost he can just
choose to dump it into things he can buy
more machines he can build a bigger
Warehouse he can build a bigger studio
and just keep spending the money they
will never see a penny yeah this looks
right this was a political judgment it's
not a legal precedent that said it's
going to get overturned you know Alex
Jones will continue to be able to
operate in Texas so I honestly I think
that probably everybody benefits from
this in the end because when it does go
to the Supreme Court and they do uphold
the Brandon Brandenburg president people
like you and I are going to be
benefiting from we're going to get the
Alex Jones president and then we're
going to be like did you see that court
case between you know Ethan Klein and
Ben Shapiro well well under the Jones
Alex Jones precedent they're going to
have to they're gonna hate that so much
they're like we got to keep bringing up
the man's name that we banned everywhere
on social media
in Jones V so um this is what happened
in Mississippi with the abortion ban
they it was what 11 weeks or something
then the left sued to stop it and it
resulted in Roe v Wade getting
overturned they could have just said hey
let's not launch any lawsuits until we
get control of the Supreme Court to keep
this level but they decided we're gonna
go we're going to go at this and try and
fight it makes the Supreme Court Supreme
Court says no Roe v Wade gone yeah see
this is why I don't take the black pill
man I am so on the white pill train
because over the long course of History
Liberty has advanced if you look at
things on a long enough timeline sure
have we lost some short-term victories
sure but the Libertarians have slowly
made gotten the big wins Roe v Wade was
a big one that was ignore that happened
last the first time I was on the show
last time and the anarchists and the
people who want to be left alone we
would see things a little bit
differently but but you do make a very
good point because especially when it
comes to states rights especially when
it comes to gun rights we have seen it
grow in in a way that the federal
government has been having a hard time
trying to of course stop you look at
people where you look at States where
people could conceal carry they're
they're becoming more and more abundant
by the day that's a huge major victory
and I I think when we look at you know
the decentralization decentralization of
power there's a lot of optimism there's
a lot of Hope but also at the same time
I think we're seeing the system panic
and kind of get angry and lash out and I
think this is one of the ways that
they're lashing out in these kind of
particular court cases but at the end of
the day we're talking about Alex Jones
someone that of course is banned on
social media and if anything this is
only going to make him more notable this
is only going to make more people know
about it because more people are talking
about them now so he was a famous guy
but they've turned him into an iconic
historical figure literally that's the
craziest thing about it a martyr yeah
but I mean just I mean more than that
Alex Jones for a while was just a
personality he was a guy who talked and
in P had fans if they left him alone he
would have ended up in the in the
history historical record as a guy who
said stuff online now they've turned him
into an extremely consequential
political and legal figure with
everything they've gone after now in
throughout history there's going to be
precedent historical records talking
about the conflict the crisis the
politics all of that stuff just simply
put he used to be influential now he's
consequential that's that's the song
lyric the left the left didn't read
their Niche they stared too long into
the abyss they fought they fought
dragons and then they became the enemy
they became exactly what they were
fighting against you know who else is
you know red pill and a lot of people
and another big victory for free speech
and freedom is Corey deangelis's Crusade
for school choice in Arizona yes he's
winning Glenn young in Virginia the
governor's race I mean what a blessing
that has been but I honestly think that
that the school choice issue and the
freedom of choice in education is the
freedom issue of our time the pandemic
red pills a lot of people but there's
nothing like telling parents that they
shouldn't have anything to do with their
kids education to get people to show up
to their town that on top of a new
record number of homeschoolers also
throughout the last few years has been
growing very significantly especially
after covid when a lot of people were
able able to actually see what's what's
happening in their curriculum what's
happening in their schools and be
shocked by the utter craziness that's
being taught to students and it's not
really teaching students or teaching
kids anything it's really indoctrinating
them into the current system a lot of
people are sick of it a lot of people
are saying you know what I'm just going
to teach my own kids the important
things that I want to teach them and
what I love too is seeing all of the
former liberals coming along to our side
right and like how the trans issue has
turned so many of the LGBT or the LGBT
well the LGBT community we get you know
Blair white and so many other
transgender people Sarah Higdon and
others who are coming along to our side
have been red pilled because of the
extremism of the progressive values the
progressives are out there attacking
Alexandria casual Cortez at a town hall
hang on yeah sticks our tongue out it's
like did she vote for funding for
Ukraine for weapons it was unanimous it
was unanimous thanks for checking out
this segment from the timcast IRL
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there